build.
This
reference
to
that
comes
decreed by.
It has been
that somehow in
free will.
There is no in
Allah has
huh
was sent to Bahrain
was sent to Al Bahin.
It is
and
excuse me
and Abu Dh
were the two that were sent to Yemen.
Now when they were sent to Yemen they
were sent to Yemen. They went there and
they called people to Islam. And when
they called people to Islam during the
year of the the year of the wu, the year
of the caravans,
the caravans that were coming to the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam in Medina
to pledge allegiance to become Muslim to
bring their zaka to meet the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam from all of
these far away lands that had heard of
Islam and become Muslim. What year was
that?
Anyone know any historians amongst us?
The ninth year after Hijra. Very good.
We have a homegrown historian here.
Mashallah. The ninth year after hij is
a group came from Yemen
and they said
they said oh messenger of Allah we came
to ask you about the beginning of this
creation.
What is the first thing that Allah
created
of this creation? Notice the wording
meaning human beings, jin, this earth,
the angels as we know them. Were their
creations before? Of course, who knows
how many creations? But Allah always was
and always is and always will be al
the
very prolific creator. Subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
And so the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam tells us of the first creation
he said.
[Silence]
He said the first thing that Allah
created was the pen.
And he said to it, "Write
and the pen responded,"What shall I
write?" Allah said, "Write all that is
to be until the day of judgment." This
writing, what that pen wrote into that
tablet, this tablet or this book is
referred to in the Quran is what?
the preserved tablet. It's also referred
at referred to as
the essence the origin of all decree
is the preserved tablets. Okay. Where
did the pen get this information from
that it wrote?
It got it from the knowledge of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
It had not yet come into existence.
You and me and my name and how many
breaths I take and how many cells in my
body and how many hairs on your head and
how many beats of your heart and what
you eat and what you don't and every bug
that you step on and everything
was written in the preserve tablet.
The prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
said and that was 50,000
years before the first creation.
Now
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala wrote this.
Does that mean that he forced it? No.
Because how is it that it would be a
forced upon us when we didn't even exist
yet? This was 50,000 years before the
creation. before the first creation,
before Gibl, before
Adam, right? And so this was 50,000
years before the creation.
Allah wrote in the preserved tablet, all
that is to be, where did that come from?
From his knowledge, subhanahu waala.
So he knows, he knew all that was to be.
And he wrote that in the preserve tablet
and it's referred to as the preserve
tablet
because it is one of eight creations of
Allah that has a beginning and has no
end.
The preserved tablet, it wasn't just
Allah wrote in it 50,000 years before
the first creation and then stopped
writing. No, no, no. It continues to
write and it will continue to write. In
Bkari Muslim, the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam said that when he arrived at
the seventh heaven on the night of
and he passed
and there is where Jirel stopped and
said I do not have permission to proceed
past this point.
So our prophet sallallah.aii Wasam went
on without
he said. And so I was then brought so
near to Allah that I could hear the pens
of decree writing.
That's how close a place that no other
prophet or messenger had ever arrived at
yet. Not even Jirel himself.
And so
this first stage
of decree, this is referred to as we
said there are four levels of decree.
Everything that comes into existence
goes through these four stages. The
first stage is what? Alaba.
The first stage is the writing. It was
written. Nothing that was not written.
Anything that was exempted from that
preserved tablet will never come into
existence.
The only thing that will come into
existence is what is in that preserved
tablet. And we said it's called the
preserved tablet because it is
preserved. It has a beginning and it has
no end.
This is one of eight things, eight
creations of Allah that has a beginning,
has no end. I've already given you one,
the preserved tablet. What do you think
if we mention the other seven? What are
the other seven creations of Allah that
have a beginning but they have no end?
They will be forever.
[Arabic recitation]
and Jenna and
the soul. Yes, correct. The soul, the
human soul.
What else? Those are three.
The hellfire. Correct. That is eternal.
There's four. We got half. We need four
more. You know them all.
Everyone here probably knows all of
them.
[Arabic recitation]
Very good. What's the tablet without the
pen? Come on, guys. They go together.
peanut butter and jelly. Like
ketchup and mustard.
the ary good. The throne of Allah.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Those six. We got two more.
So, we've got
the tablet, the pen, the hellfire,
paradise, the soul of the human being,
and the throne of Allah. Got two more.
[Arabic recitation]
is temporary. And alhamdulillah, it's
temporary.
No, that's part of Jenna.
That has that is not created. It's not
part of creation.
Mhm.
[Arabic recitation]
Al is part of Jenna.
Al is part of
is part of Jenna, right? The Quran is
the words of Allah. It's part of his
attributes. Has no beginning or end.
It's uncreated. Now, a hint. It goes
with the
alsi.
Als
the same thing? No. Als and ar